about 400 years before the time of Game
of Thrones or 200 years before the time
of uh House of the
Dragon the Valyrian Peninsula
exploded and it was called the Doom of
Valaria and it was over in a day it was
over in a few hours it actually blew the
entire section to land cracked the sea
rushed in from both sides there's now a
very dangerous Sea called the smoking
Sea north of Valaria they sort of
breaking the former peninsula in half
what used to be lands attached to each
other are now some Barren Windswept
islands and of course hundreds of
dragons died in an instant along with
millions of
people and that was of course the Doom
that Dan's the dreamer had seen coming
so get the hell out and uh and the
targaryens got the hell out to establish
themselves on Dragon stor for free you
can now listen to the entire audiobook
Fire and Blood On which house of the
Dragon is based and which covers the
entire Targaryen history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a notable trial
using our Link in the
description this world wasn't always so
small and
Petty thousands of years ago while the
rest of men prayed to gods the valyrians
became them through magic or sheer will
they mastered the greatest creatures in
history a horse grants man dominion over
the land a ship over the sea but dragons
gave us the sky and everything and
everyone beneath
it at its height my ancestors ruled the
Known World whatever parts we didn't
weren't worth knowing our capital of
valyria shamed the Magnificent cities of
the East for Hammers and chisels were no
match for Dragon Fire and
sorcery it was a city and an empire
built to last until the end of
time it
didn't 400 years ago the Doom fell on
Vala mountains cracked open like eggs
lakes and rivers boiled Fountains of
fire Ash and smoke spewed from the
ground so high and so hot that even
dragons burned in
Flight the land splinted and the angry
sea rushed in in hours the greatest City
in history became history but my
ancestors didn't burn or drown with the
rest of their race 12 years before the
Doom despite the snear of his Rivals
Anar Targaryen abandoned the capital
with his family Legends claimed that his
daughter forsaw the destruction of the
city in a dream more likely Anar met
with some mishap at court and chose
exile over
execution he and House Targaryen slinked
away to a dreary remote godforsaken
island forsaken no
longer with Arts now lost to the world
we transformed a tiny Outpost into into
Dragon Stone a fortress fit for the last
dragon Lords then Ana's descendants
settled into it like a tomb for their
lost
Homeland until
Aon when he looked East he saw the past
old tired dead but when he looked
West he saw the
future gold in the ground gold in the
fields and no dragons in the the sky but
his Westeros has Mighty Rivers but none
of them compare to the roin it is said
that there is no stream or puddle in
Western essers but drains to Mother Roy
no doubt in
exaggeration until one sees the river at
its widest a man in the center can't see
a Shore to either side the greatest of
mother roin's children were the Roa a
civilization as ancient and Grand as old
gese Fishers Traders Scholars workers of
wood Stone and metal the roer raised the
elegant cities from the headwaters of
the roin down to her mouth each Lovelier
than the last for many centuries the
roer lived in relative peace when
Invaders swept down from the hills the
roer woman and men would Dawn Silver
Scaled Armor Fish Head Helms tall Spears
and turtle shell Shields if the enemy
did not laugh themselves away it was
said that mother roin would whisper the
enemy secrets to her children and the
royish Wizards could raise watery walls
to drown their foes whatever magic the
roer may have had it wasn't enough when
Valyrian colonists first arrived the
Royer embraced them for all men were
welcome to share the Bounty of mother
Roy perhaps a water people should have
been more cautious of strangers who
exalted Fire and Blood Legend has it
that one day the valyrians netted and
butchered one of the giant turtles the
roer held sacred as a result thousands
were killed or enslaved cities and towns
were burned drowned and rebuilt in these
wars the valerians emerged as Victorious
more often than not the princes of the
roin Cities fiercely proud of their
independence fought alone whilst the
Valyrian colonies aided one another
eventually the royish princes ceased
their squabbling and United behind
Prince Garin who led the largest army OS
had ever seen against 100,000 Lian
colonists 100 war elephants and three
dragon Lords thousands burned but
thousands more sheltered in the shallows
of the river whilst the royish Wizards
raised enormous water spouts against the
fo's dragons royish archers brought down
two of the Dragons whilst the third fled
wounded and thereafter the roer named
Garen the great but mother Vala proved
just as caring as mother Roy when Garin
the great Mar his Army against valantis
300 Valyrian dragons descended from the
sky tens of thousands burned whilst
others rushed into the river but the
fires burned so hot that the water
boiled and turned to steam Garin the
great was captured alive and made to
watch as valyrians butchered every last
man so many that their blood turned the
great Harbor of valantis red as far as
the eye could see then they forced Garin
to watch as they marched on his own City
and enslaved all the women and children
his army had left behind the singers
claimed that Prince Garin called out
mother Roy to curse the valyrians and
she in turn flooded the city with foul
Waters and a damp fog that caused the
skin of the valyrians to harden and
crack and thus was born grayscale
fearing a similar fate another royish
ruler princess namia led her own people
into every ship skiff and raft they had
and fled esos eventually after much
hardship they landed in sunswept and
bone dry Dawn but we all know that Tale
Now Vala has followed the roer out of
this world and her daughters have grown
into free cities wealthy and powerful
and proud still mother Roy flows on past
ancient ruins and bustling Harbors
sweeping all man's kingdoms to the
Sea according to Legend House Targaryen
survived the Doom of valyria thanks
thanks to danies the dreamer who forsaw
the Calamity and convinced her father to
flee their Homeland it could be true the
targaryens were always a bit more but as
ma yendle points out in the East the
targaryens were one of a thousand minor
noble families and in Westeros they
became Kings politics not prophecy could
have drawn them to our
Shores east of Westeros lies the smoking
sea where no ship dares Sail
there are those who swear it to be demon
haunted and who's to say they're wrong
for it was there thousands of years ago
that a cataclysmic event occurred
destroying one of the great
civilizations in
history the precise details of their
Origins are lost to us but it is said
the valyrians were once a modest
community of shepherds tending their
flocks on a small peninsula of the Great
Eastern
continent one fateful day in a volcanic
area known as the 14 fires they made a
shattering
Discovery
dragons they were monstrous scaled
creatures with massive Wings sharp claws
and fiery breath they were also said to
have a deep rooted connection to
Magic In Time the valyrians were able to
tame the beasts harnessing their immense
power they established a city of Wonder
unlike any before or since
they became skilled at sorcery and
Metallurgy creating uncommon weapons of
spell forged
steel wielding these weapons arried
their dragons the valyrians conquered
the surrounding lands and slowly
expanded
West at the time the gari Empire
dominated much of the Great Eastern
continent and tried to stop Vala's
expansion the gaskari legions attacked
the valyrians five times but could never
defeat them them finally the valyrians
marched on their Capital old giz and
obliterated it turning its streets and
buildings to Ash with dragon flame and
wiping the gusari people and their
culture off the face of the
Earth the Freehold of valyria as it came
to be known became the most advanced
civilization in the known world with its
own language gods and culture the
Valyrian reach extended far and wide
covering most of of the
continent great cities were built and
roadways paved all of which led back to
valyria the Freehold would Prosper for
nearly 5,000
years but it was not to last an event
that became known only as the Doom laid
waste to the valyrians their capital
city and its surrounding
lands the peninsula itself was shattered
becoming what is now the smoking sea
every Dragon was thought to be lost as
were the Valyrian spells knowledge and
recorded
history thus the mighty Empire
collapsed what caused this
cataclysm no one knows for certain some
say it was a volcanic eruption others
say the Valyrian own sorcery got the
better of them in any event the Doom's
Devastation of the Valyrian people was
total with the exception of a small
rocky island in the narrow sea
Dragonstone for it was there that the
targaryens the last of old valyria
dwell they would lie and wait for
another 100 years before unleashing the
fury of the Dragon on another
continent Wester
us